day three of the Grantchester here in  northern the best chess players in the  world battle for maximal points on the  crew so final day of rapid frenchman  mixing by sheila Groff came back from  the dead against this what about unarmed  and found himself at the end of the day  sitting alone in clear Sutton Place and  I kept on fighting sixteen much bigger  coordinate leader Wesley so continue to  make Jeff look easy  and he's comfortably manage to increases  weed over his knee responders yeah  hopefully after they like this every  single sermon because that's got they of  my play here it's much higher than the  one in Empire it's also blue we're  lighting fast hands and nerves of steel  will decide the winners stay for action  starts right now